so back to show their models everywhere
it looks like absolute madness can you
describe the vibe to us it's really
exciting to be here in China I think
every one of us we're looking forward to
this day and everyone the Angels have
been working very hard to be part of it
is every model dream to be in this
unbelievable event of magnitude that is
the Victoria's Secret Show over 190
countries will be watching and I believe
this year even here at the venue we're
gonna have over 3,000 people watching
it's really big
this is your 18th show do you ever still
get nerves and jitters before you get up
there I do every single time I thought
over the years I would get like not
nervous but now I still get excited in
nervous I think if you ask a lot of
people who their favorite angel would be
they would say you but who do you have a
favorite the most iconic Victoria see
Vermont well I I have a few I have a few
I think every single angel has something
in particular that from them like I
think Heidi Klum has amazing funny
character and and also how she became a
businesswoman that's really inspired to
me
Laetitia Casta this is the time when I
stuttered you know I studied in 1999 and
to me she was like super like a peanut
beautiful peanut girl there is for the
girls today
liddie Lily Aldridge she's a sweetheart
and she's genuine and so cute and I love
her so there is always something from my
angel that you can get and learn
something
from them I know a lot of people are
also looking forward to the musical
guests tonight between Harry Styles and
Miguel who would you rather go on a
sightseeing tour of Shanghai with all of
them I would take all of them with me
but I would take them to the you garden
I would take them to the Oriental Pearl
Tower it's just you know take a picture
up there from the city and maybe a nice
dinner oh and also living in the living
like the nation's cities the water city
I think your name and we could go and
have they could take me out actually why
don't you guys take me out I'm thinking
I'm taking notes for you know for for
this trip to Shanghai as a friend as a
friend